so our last story today
um is actually
about Troy Francis so Troy Francis has
been on the show a couple times
a relationship but particularly when
you're in a domestic relief you know
what's funny though the one thing that
stops your testosterone from dropping in
those relationships do you know
get cheat on your girl Sensations I'm
just a scientist so Troy Francis has
been on the show a couple times and he
had a tweet today
um that really made
conservative and liberal Twitter go
crazy okay so
Troy says a high value man is a bachelor
in his 40s and 50s has a vasectomy Child
free by choice travels extensively uh
reads voriciously swims in the sea every
morning in sunshine enjoys the very best
of Life unfettered by the concerns and
responsibilities that others have so
here's an interesting thing guys okay
um I want to just point out how it's so
interesting when men get a vasectomy how
Twitter just gets so triggered and and I
want to have an honest conversation
about this we know that the reputation
of marriage is bad okay
we know that women have a nature okay
we know that women's nature when we tend
to get power we aren't very nice with it
when we tend to get leverage we aren't
very nice with it uh my evidence for
this is in the last hundred years when
policy makers have had to cater to women
to get elected women have elected
politicians that have passed unfair
child support alimony divorce laws child
custody laws and really policies that in
my eyes only benefit women women's
nature is just very selfish I Can't Tell
You Why
um completely it's this way but I see no
evidence that it's any other way now
does that mean every woman acts on her
nature no but the problem is we can't
have honest conversations about these
topics because everybody thinks their
woman is special and I've interviewed
many men that thought their women was
were special when um they got married
and then they found out that she was
exactly the same and the truth of the
matter is that Instagram changes women
it gives us leverage to the point or at
least perceived leverage to the point
where we think we are better than the
men that are on our level and I don't I
don't think this can really be disputed
when you see women calling themselves
tense and let's look at the media when
women have been pandered to in the media
it's often at the expense of men when
women get power over men we're not very
nice with it
so the the reputation of marriage is bad
we can all agree on this so 50 roughly
please don't argue with me about five
percent okay fifty percent of marriages
fail all right now let's look at the
other 50 if the reputation of marriage
is bad that tells us that at least half
of the people that stayed married are
not in marriages that most people would
deem desirable and when you look at
numbers that go through
um I don't know
sexlessness when you look at numbers
that go through marital satisfaction
um we're looking at a 75 plus failure
rate of marriage
um yet
people can push marriage with no
pushback now I I don't say to get
married or to not get married what I try
to do is explain how these policies
affect everything right now the value of
women is lower and lower we're offering
less kids less Purity less youth
um we it's very on it's very rare to see
women actually serve men
um when uh you when you ask a question
to a couple typically you see the woman
answering instead of the man
um indicating that she's leading the
relationship
um instead of the guy when you look at
more traditional relationships you see
the woman looking to the man you see a
man being publicly disrespected you see
wives looking like on Instagram
this is common and not every woman will
do it but we don't acknowledge women's
nature and we also see women that were
quote unquote good women and that did
things the right way let's let's say the
Steven Crowder thing they both waited
till they were married got married after
a couple months on both Christians and
it seemed like that was the right path
and yet women are women and when women
get leverage over men they're just not
very nice with it
and so what Troy does is
his version of a high value man right is
taking reproductive power into his own
hands you know ninety percent of women
have been on birth control and I know
women personally that are infertile
because of it yet you don't see the same
visceral reaction to women getting an
IUD to women taking the Depo shot to
women on the pill you don't see that but
whenever men take fertility into their
own hands we can't have an honest
conversation about it and you know
tradcons will always sell marriage as
kids marriage and kids is the answer and
you know as a woman like I I want it to
be but I think when you have a 75 plus
failure rate it's disingenuous to say
just find a good woman and get married
um because women are still women and
even good women when tempted by the law
child support alimony the entire media
and culture telling you to leave your
marriage a lot of women are gonna take
them up on that and unfortunately
um we're we're really gonna keep seeing
a lot of divorce in my hand in my in my
mind or a lack of marriage
so now what you see is you see the Trad
cons just getting very pissed and and we
just we need to have an honest
conversation about it guys I've
interviewed so many men that are
absolutely worse off because they got
married this idea that marriage and kids
those men are are happier than the
others I I don't see it I see the
opposite I see men that are disrespected
in their own home I see men that are in
sexless marriages and I see the
occasional happy couple but I I see more
unhappy than happy and this is just me
being honest it's not what I want to see
but
um again with the reputation of marriage
being what it is I don't know how you
can argue with it
so
um this guy says married since my early
20s not snipped two kids with my wife
unfortunately unable to have more only
really travel to visit family mostly
reading parenting and theology books but
not as much as I'd like swim in my pool
a couple of times a week tired but
fulfilled and you know there's nothing
wrong with that either and that that's
what like you hope right but a hope
isn't what the numbers are telling us
and unfortunately you know
I I think the biggest mistake people
make is thinking they're special most
people are exactly the same most women
are exactly the same
now um I would strongly advise against
getting a vasectomy I met a bunch of
these type of expats in South America
the freedom of being a man is you can
start a family at any age agreed the
vasectomy part is a no no most high
value men would Delight in having
children at some point okay but guys I
want you I just want you to like think
about this so we know that men getting
married young and I'm not saying to get
a vasectomy this is what they're going
to say pearls push in for a vasectomy my
no my whole point is we can't have an
honest conversation about the pros and
cons of a decision okay so let's let's
think about this we know that met young
men have a hard time in dating so a lot
of men will come to the conclusion
um
I wanna I wanna wait till I'm older to
get married so I have a little more
leverage now there are guys that just
want to make sure they don't ever slip
up because the idea of them being
abstinent for 15 years if you want to
sell that to men good luck okay it's
like yeah you have to be abstinate until
you're 35. okay
um so a lot of guys just don't want to
take that risk now it's interesting
because the majority of vasectomies are
reversible
but the majority of marriages fail
so why is one
so triggering but the other is not and
if you say that's a bad idea you're
shamed
that's what I don't get
now
um this one guy says what is it with
these aging red pill homo see and this
is I'll tell you what's happening there
his worldview is collapsing because
we've been sold the dream that kids like
if you kids are are the passage to
happiness and I would agree if they're
your kids but in the west the children
are not yours men have no legal rights
not really with their children women are
almost always going to be granted
custody women are the ones that are
going to put you on child support and
oftentimes women will be in the kid's
ear if it doesn't work out telling the
kids how awful you are and then now it's
like okay you have a 22 year old that
hates you is that better
uh and I'm not I I'm not saying that it
you can't have good children but the
idea like my question is why is one
so triggering but like we can't have an
honest conversation about it like why
can't you have a conversation about this
without
um going back to aging red pill homos
what is it with these aging red pill
homos trying to meme getting a vasectomy
as this great thing
um and again I'm not saying it's a great
thing I I think it's really I think the
real solution is changing
child custody laws I think the real
solution is changing marriage law I but
I think in the time being a vasectomy is
what some guys are going to choose all
right guys you know let me know what you
think guys get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt you know I I know
a lot of you guys
are are saying I got other stuff I want
to spend my money on blah blah blah blah
guys guys it helps support the channel
right and then we can really start to
make waves on repealing the 19th you
know what I mean guys seriously and plus
it's actually hilarious all you got to
do people come up to you they're like
What's with your shirt and you just you
just look at them you're like dead
serious
and and I just have the same answer you
know we can't pick boyfriend
so why should we pick the leader of the
Free World I don't know it's fine get
yourself a t-shirt like the video on
your way out subscribe to the channel
and let me know what you want me to
cover next time on another episode of
pearl daily I'll talk to you guys later